belle frayeur hier pour les vacanciers
d'un camping de port grimaud dans le var
un incendie s'est déclaré chez huawei ah
oui c'est impressionnant d'un incendie
s'est déclaré dans un mobile-home il
s'est ensuite propagé à une vingtaine
d'heures à l'origine du feu reste pour
l'heure inconnue les dégâts sont
matériels trois personnes ont été
intoxiquées et sont suivis mais aucun
blessé grave n'est pas déclaré sa caisse
aussi son patient bien cuites au
barbecue le même grief boris leclercq
lui cherche désespérément son futur chef
cuisinier depuis un mois il a lancé il
ya quelques jours un appel sur la page
instagram de son restaurant la personne
qui me rend beau monde un chef de
cuisine
typique italien
je lui offre 20 gros billets de 50 euros
ce qui fait mille euros le par messaoud
fleury
simonet
le premier face il est pour bibi s'il
vous plaît merci c'est génial
[Applaudissements]
j'ai beaucoup d'amis et je suis très
famille on est souvent en cercle fermé
donc moi ont très mal sorte de fer jazz
laurent au bord d'un autre
prénom âge sexe profession à quoi
ressemble le député type le profil type
de votre député en évidemment inscrits
mais toute la précédente assemblée est
bien le candidat aux législatives à une
cinquantaine d'années et c'est un homme
bref le candidat type à une prostate et
surtout ils doivent bien penser à cela
faire palper tous les ans
en lingerie quelle partie du corps la
braguette pauvres tel prélèvement ne pas
l'être
j'ai quitté le ch'nord oui entre les
aéroports oui je suis parti en corrèze
ah bah oui alors là oui d'accord
exactement le pays de la bonne
gastronomie
je sais pas on est sur antenne 2 donc
gastronomie avec moi sur scène depuis 25
ans
on peut pêcher à la branlette ou à la
touchette
à la touche atteint à la branlette
et là vous à venir la pêche à la
branlette mais de quoi s'agit-il
c'est une technique de pêche qui se
pratique en donnant un mouvement
continuel à l' amorce de la ligne pour
attirer les poissons
et on apprend aussi que si on se fie
donc à cette assemblée le meilleur le
meilleur prêt donc pu être dans
l'assemblée c'est jean-pierre philippe a
dit oui oui et je pense que certains ont
lu l'article de la montagne puisque
voici la fiche d'un candidat
j'ai fait face politique pour moi s'il
vous plaît heureusement qu'il ya le foot
me dit à franck leboeuf qui ne regardent
trop finale de coupe du monde sur six
est de gagner gaza alors faut pas que
franck leboeuf se marie avec la banane
bourguignons qui ministre
ministre de la santé parce que là
je dis qu'il faut pas que monsieur
leboeuf se marient que madame
bourguignon c'est tout ce qu'il faut
savoir de pas trop sur ces 20 minutes
qui nous fait cet article et alors il ya
un candidat c'est assez amusant qui
s'appelle nicolas françois karasiewicz
je peux pas faire de conneries pas mal
dire des non-voyants et son mouvement
s'appelle une vision nouvelle du
territoire et je trouve ça assez rigolo